From the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.
This is Emilye Crosby and it's May 29, 2017, 2013.
I'm here with John Bishop and we're interviewing Mr. (Lonnie C.) King,
in one of the Southwest Library grants of the Fortin County Library here in Atlanta
as part of the Southern World History Project.
Civil Rights History Project sponsored by the Smithsonian Museum of African American History and Culture in the Library of Congress.
I think the American History Project.
And so Mr. (Lonnie C.) King, we're very pleased that you're with us here today.
Well, thank you very much for coming to record my comments about this great era in our history.
So you're talking about your family and your early background?
Yes, I was born in a little town called Arlington, Georgia,
which is down 27 miles southwest of Albany.
The county was Calhoun County.
My mother's name was Bertha Lee Smith King and she was one of 17 children.
My father's name was LC King Senior.
He had about seven or eight brothers and brothers and sisters.
They divorced when I was about two, I guess.
And I stayed with my grandfather until I was eight.
My grandfather kept me real until he died and then they sent me to Atlanta to be with my mother.
I guess Dr. Emilye Crosby, if I had to pinpoint my beginnings, I have to say I believe that I was born looking up at the bottom.
I was not on the bottom. I was looking up at the bottom. I was up there.
So the likelihood that I might even go to college,
much less finished college and do some other things, was probably a little remote,
considering the environment that I grew up in.
However, I have to attribute a great deal of my desire for freedom and my passion,
and my commitment, and I guess my long distance running attitude to my grandfather,
who was my mentor, his Reverend Joseph P. Smith.
He was an evangelist who also was a note singer with perfect pitch in his voice.
He was a tremendous person.
And a lot of my feelings about matters and attitudes about matters today flow from those years,
those six years I was under his tutelage.
And as I reflect in talking to you now, I guess it's akin to what John Locke once said,
that what you teach a child in the first six years of their lives will influence how they're going to be for the rest of their lives.
But you write on that blank slate.
I guess my granddad wrote a few things on my blank slate.
One of the things that I know he wrote on my blank slate was the fact that one day we had to change the system.
I remember in 1942, I was walking home from school in the first grade,
and I saw my first plane crop duster, dropped leaflets.
That was where they campaigned during those days in rural areas.
And so I picked up one of the leaflets and took it home,
and I could read every word, understood every word that I read,
because he had taught me the read before I went to school.
But that was one word that I didn't understand.
Now this now, the crop duster was hired by Eugene Talmadge, who was running for governor at that time.
I said, granddad, what is a nigger?
He said, where'd you get that from?
I said, the plane just dropped us and I picked it up.
And I can understand everything, but I have never heard of a nigger.
I don't even keep a nigger in his place.
Keep the nigger in his place.
He said, come on and sit on my knee, let me talk to you.
He proceeded to tell me about Talmich and about racism.
A comment that he made to me sticks with me today, he said, Dom,
you know, we're still in a form of slavery.
The difference is that we can go home at night.
And we don't have anybody who's that assigned overseer.
But for all practical purposes, the system that we're in is one that is oppressive, so forth, and so on.
As fate would have it a few weeks later, I happened to be at the kitchen table with he and my grandmother, with him and my grandmother.
And I saw these on the lobes on the table.
And I was an inquisitive kid.
No, Z. I picked it up and I said, granddaddy, what is the national association for the vastness of colored people?
He said, that's a national civil rights organization.
And I'm recruiting memberships for them.
50 cents, I believe at that time.
He said, son, one day, this organization's going to set us free.
He said, they've got lawyers in New York and so forth and so on.
So when you look at that kind of orientation that I heard of preach on Sundays about freedom and so forth and so on,
he was painting on my blank slate or writing on my blank slate a kind of add to resistance added to two racism and discrimination that I think served me well in 1960.
What were the churches?
Actually, he was an evangelist so he didn't even have a church.
He was always on the circuit preaching at different churches all over that part of Southwest Georgia and Northeast Alabama.
You might have been younger than those things that you wouldn't have known this, but I think that's right around the time that the basic was traveling around in that area.
Do you have any ideas you might have come to?
I don't know whether I actually came through there or not. That was 1941-42.
She was with the NAACP at that time.
She was there coming to think of it.
She had two strengths at the NAACP, I think.
I think it was a position.
I think I can't remember what they call a person made of steel.
That was fair and direct.
I don't know whether my mother, she ever met my grandfather.
She probably did, to be honest with you, but I was a little kid.
What kind of work did you do when you started doing this?
He was a farmer.
He was a sharecropper.
He had ten acres that he rented from some man that owned the property.
They would divide up in the fall, whatever.
I don't know whether or not he ever broke even.
I just know that he was a sharecropper.
I used to go to the field.
I was too young to do any work, so I would go and watch him.
I never forget an anecdote here.
I had ventured down into the corn field part of these ten acres.
I ran into a rattlesnake.
Of course, I knew to run from a rattlesnake.
When I got back to the wagon, I said, Granddaddy,
I just ran upon a rattlesnake down here.
I said, I just ran a puddle on Granddaddy.
I said, I'm going down here.
If I don't find a rattlesnake, I'm going to thank you.
I said, Granddaddy, you don't think the rattlesnake is going to wait for you to come down there.
Do you? Come on.
He went down and he didn't find a rattlesnake,
but he did not beat me either.
These anecdote really do, I guess, make me feel good when I think about the man
and what he did for me.
One of the things he used to tell me is that you need to always try to tell the truth
when something comes up.
It's easier to tell the truth than to lie.
Because when you lie, you got to remember the lie in order to not get caught in the lie.
So just tell the truth and it keeps coming out right.
All those kinds of things make a difference when you're young and coming up.
It must have been in the past, so you're difficult to do anything that has been passed
and passed away.
It was terrible.
But I came here at eight years of age and I guess we can move on into Atlanta now.
My mother was a member of Ebenezer Baptist Church.
So I came in March and they had the spring revival in April.
So Martin Luther King Sr opened the doors of the church.
That first night that I went to the revival.
My mother was in the choir.
So when they opened the doors of the church, I got up and I went down and I joined.
I could see my mother looking to me.
I had not talked to her about it.
And she had some concern I could tell.
So when we got on the bus to go home, she said,
you didn't tell you to go on the church.
I said, well, we didn't talk about it.
She said, well, do you know what you're doing?
I said, yes, I know what I'm doing.
So she didn't say anything more about it.
I was shocked that I did it at eight.
Anyway.
But while I had Ebenezer, I was there from 45 until 54 when I went into the military.
My mother, she took me to church almost every day in the week.
That was something going on.
And when I went to the church, she had me at the YMCA.
And I'll cover that later.
But anyway, while I was there at Ebenezer Baptist Church,
Martin Luther King Sr, Alberta Williams King,
was always asking me to lead something, hit something.
And that was when I formed something called the Ebenezer Youth Organization
that's still running down there now.
I was the first chairman of the organized organization.
But that's also when I met his children.
A.D. (Alfred Daniel) King. and I had a paper route together.
And of course, (Martin) Luther King Jr was a little older than A.D. (Alfred Daniel) King.
And I always knew that he was going to be a great preacher,
because on Thursday nights, while my mother was there,
regurghershin downstairs with the choir,
he'd be upstairs practicing his preaching.
Because that was the pastor, so he could get the key.
So Martin King, he's almost like he never played.
He was always serious.
So he would be in there, you know, did he?
Practice, practice, practice.
Did you have a lot for me?
Did you feed back?
No, I didn't.
We were just friends.
And I guess it probably helped.
My name was the same as theirs.
And so they knew who I was.
And that may have been reason why the bother kept asking me to do things.
So they had the same name.
That served me well later on during the movement,
which I'm sure we're talking about later on.
So it sounds like you really much,
very much, you could learn from your black institutions,
from my family.
Yes, yes.
The Butler Street YMCA,
and just into the church, my mother,
took me down to the Butler Street YMCA,
when I was eight, before I even started to school,
because she kept me out of school for several months,
because I was eight,
but I was promoted to the fifth grade,
and she felt I was going too fast.
And so she had me sit at home from March until September.
She said, because if I let you go,
you might get promoted to the sixth grade,
and you would just be nine.
She said, I'm not sure, well, I want to do that.
So I had to sit home and what have you.
But she also went down to the Butler Street YMCA,
and he started why this now closed, believe it or not,
but it was organized 1890 something.
She asked me to go down there,
and I went, well, when I just learned,
as I've been writing for my dissertation,
I interviewed a man who's 85 years old,
and I interviewed him because he was around that land,
and during that time, I knew he was around the Y.
His name is Mr. Eugene Thomas.
Very lucid man, retired from the public school system.
So I went to see Mr. Thomas,
and I said, Mr. Thomas, let me talk to you about my tenure at the Y,
and also about Atlanta and the environment in the forties,
when you were an adult here,
he said, okay, and we talked about all of that,
but he said, but specifically, talk about you.
He said, I was there.
He was an assistant to Mr. J. D. Winston,
who was the director of the What Boys division at that time.
And so he told me that my mother came down there
to see Mr. Winston in 1945,
to tell her that she had a son who was coming in to Atlanta
from Odinton, Georgia,
and she wanted me to come down there and wanted him to look out for me
while I was down there,
and that I should not let me leave there until 6 o'clock,
because by that time, you would have chance to get home
from her job as a maid,
and Mr. Winston agreed to that.
I did not know until I talked to Mr. Thomas
that she came down there another time,
just to see how things were going,
and more than other Mr. Winston,
if I was a good boy or a bad boy,
because if I was a bad boy,
she was going to whip my line right there.
I said, okay, I didn't know any of this stuff.
It was all done behind my back,
but I guess for my benefit though.
Those were some good times,
our young people could,
when parents were not necessarily afraid of molestation
of their children by people.
Nowadays, you have to watch out,
you don't know what's going to go on.
But during those days, people trusted one another,
people looked out for the kids,
and then those things had a tremendous bearing on you.
So I grew up in the Bell Street,
and I left there in 1954.
So first of all, I was there so much until they hired me.
They hired me down there.
At $0.50 a day,
and I was just around just helping.
I was a little help around there.
And I knew I had gotten paid $0.50 a day,
for basically just kind of being there,
picking up tiles, you name it.
And I said, Mr. Thomas,
just don't know me.
Where did you get the budget to pay me $0.50 a day?
He said, there was no budget.
I said, well, where did the money come from?
He said, we all chipped in $0.50 a piece.
In other words, he said, we paid it.
The old senior staff put together a little money
to pay this $0.89 10-year-old kid.
I was shocked that that had happened,
but it happened.
Dr. Emilye Crosby, I believe,
when you're born all done,
you look at all these things.
God was preparing me for 1960,
because while I was at the YMCA
for all those years,
I ran into all the movers and shakers in Atlanta,
in the Black community.
They were down there playing bridge.
And I'm the little kid around there watching them play bridge,
and I learned table tennis,
and I taught a lot of them how to play table tennis.
I was like a little mascot that was always around.
So when the movement thing,
when Greensboro erupted,
as I reflect back now,
I had been prepared for leadership of the movement in Atlanta,
because in order to make it work,
I had to find a way to merge the town and the gown.
And because I had met so many people at the Y,
that knew me from when I was a child,
that helped me a great deal when I called them
to ask, can I get your help?
One more thing that I think is important in my development.
My mother was amazed,
so she couldn't pay my tuition at Morehouse.
I had gone over there on a partial scholarship,
but didn't have enough to really have a full scholarship.
So I decided to do something that I had said I'd never do,
which is to go into military.
And I went into the Navy,
and I went there because the Navy offered me a chance to come in
on what they call a Kitty Cruise.
That would be three years.
If you win before you 18,
you get out the day before you 21.
And so I went in just before I was 18,
got out in three years.
While I was in the Navy,
I ran in some of the most virulent races
that you could ever encounter under the umbrella
of the United States of America.
When I was in boot camp,
I was the educational pay officer for my 80-some guys
who was in my group.
My job was to teach them the three hours,
you know, all of a sudden,
to graduate after 11 weeks.
When I finished,
I was in charge of about 20 people who went to
the USS Riscanae Actcraft Carrier in California.
So I had all the records and everything.
So when I got there,
and we saluted the office of the day,
we came on board,
they sent us down to something called the X-1 Division.
That's the orientation division for two weeks.
So when we finished the orientation division,
we went to Virginia.
They then gave us all a billet.
They all gave us a job.
So I was the only black person
of the folks who were 19 white people plus me.
Every last white person got a good job
by that I mean either as a young man,
which is the same as a secretary,
air control and fire control,
when you name it, those jobs that were,
that you had some relationship,
those jobs to a civilian career,
except two people in the group.
Two of us were sent to the deck force,
to chip paint and mop and scrub and you name it.
That was me.
I had to hire GCT in the group,
and the young guy from Kentucky,
had the lowest GCT.
Now I knew all that stuff because I was in charge of the record.
So the black guy and the white guy
with the lowest GCT get a sign to the deck force.
It's too late to get out by that time,
because I'm there.
So I go down to begin my work,
chip and paint.
Well that wasn't enough.
I got a call after I was done about a month
and I was going to be assigned to another job.
And this time I was assigned the job of cleaning the head.
Now the head was the restroom for 200 people
who worked in the deck force on the aircraft carrier.
That's a jazzed job, basically, you follow me?
So I went up there
and I remember something Dr. May said when I was a freshman.
He said,
when you go to a more house college,
you need to do the very best that you can.
Whatever job you do,
do it better than anybody else other than God.
And if it's your fate to be a lawyer,
be the best lawyer, be the best preacher, best doctor.
But if fate falls upon you
where you have to be a ditch digger,
be the best ditch digger that's ever been born.
And I said, well, mine wasn't ditch digging
but it was cleaning up this restroom.
So I said, let me take his ammunition.
And so I went out and I requisitioned paint,
brass polish, you name it.
And I turned the place into
a very nice looking well lit bright bathroom.
So therefore, I only had to work maybe a half hour in the morning,
a half hour and a half afternoon after the lunch.
The rest of the time I could read books.
And I want you to know that what I had created
was so appealing to a third class petty officer
put in a petition to bump me out of that job
and put me back in the deck for us.
So you made cleaning the bathroom and you looked like a good job?
Any job that you would make in the south,
it seems to me that would, that some whites would say,
you know, I'd rather have that job,
put that nigger out of here.
And so that's what happened to me.
So then I applied for dental technician school.
But you had to have two years left.
So they sent me a acceptance one year,
11 months and 29 days to go on my enlistment,
which meant that I had to sign up for an additional year.
I said, I'm not going to do this.
I'm not going to put out with this.
As fate would have it,
the dispersing office put out a request for someone
to become a dispersing clerk striker.
It is a dispersing clerk train E.
And I applied for it.
The division officer called me down to have an interview.
I'm an N.S.J.C. Claren, K.L.A.R.E. in.
Claren asked me, why did I apply?
And I thought I could do the job.
Can you type?
I said no, but I can learn how to do it.
He said, well, I'm paraphrasing now.
He said, we don't want any knee growth down here.
All the folks in here from the South,
you know, it would just not be the thing.
I said, wait a minute, my parents paid taxes too,
and I just like that, parents.
Yeah, but it wouldn't work.
I want you to see them chaperone on the ship
and tell them about my flight.
He said, do you pay for that?
I said, yes, they did.
I said, I don't believe I said, yes, they did.
He didn't do a thing, but just take the notes down.
So I'm now back on the deck for us.
And I decided that I would ask the division officer
who was over the deck for us for an appointment.
And that was a lieutenant, J.G. Horn,
H.R.R. Indy from Louisiana.
I forgot the name of the town in Louisiana.
And I went in and I told him the same thing that I told the chaplain.
J.G. Horn listened to me.
He said, come with me.
He took me down to that same instant who said,
did he want me down there?
Lieutenant J.G. Horn said, Mr. King tells me,
that was first of all, he said, Mr. King,
I was surprised at that.
He said, Mr. King said, and he told him the story.
Is that true?
He said, well, they don't want him down here.
He said something that is true.
Yes, he said, if his name is not in the plan of the day
tomorrow, he will be transferred down here.
I'm going to go to the chief of the native personnel
and get your commission.
He said, Mr. King, come with us, go.
The next morning, my name is that plan of the day,
to be transferred down because of that white man down in Louisiana
who stepped up to the plate to tell another white man you're wrong.
You said you were not asking me when you were born?
Nope, so I'm all the time, but he was speaking,
I speak, but never.
That was nothing.
You had a hierarchy.
You had the division officer, then you had a chief on petty officer,
then you had a first class, then you had a second class,
then you had some third classes.
I was just a little seam on your podium.
So no, they didn't really talk to you unless they wanted to see you.
They passed by and be friendly, but the point is you had no contact
with the person.
Did you think you did that particularly at some point for you?
No, I think he did because I think he thought it was fair,
and I'm not right.
Now, I may be wrong, but I'm just telling you what happened.
That's how I got down there.
So when I got there, the guys wouldn't talk to me.
They were just angry, I guess, because I had broken the cut-align
on that ship.
One guy named Welty Wolf from Seattle, Washington,
was in that group, and he was a guy who had been to dispersion school,
and one day he came over to me and he said,
Lonnie, I've been there for weeks now.
I've never been to talk to me anything.
I was just there.
He said, I went to dispersion school and said,
are you willing to stay on board ship and learn this stuff?
I said, yeah, he said, I'll teach you.
He said, but it's going to be quite easy.
You can take the exam.
The next exam is in November.
This is August of 1954.
August of 1955.
So I started studying all the books and then another guy named John Bloom
from Tempe, Arizona, who also was in that group,
joined in to help Welty Wolf.
He wanted to teach me how to type.
Make a long story short.
I took the exam with four other white guys,
four third class petty officer in November.
When the results came back, I was only one who passed.
So all of a sudden, now they got it.
They didn't want down there.
Now it's one of the buses.
Revolution down there.
So I stayed there and I became staff sergeant, or DK5,
and then I got out.
I was talking to a good friend of mine by the name of Everett Render,
R-E-N-D-E-R, who was my manager when I was a prize fatty in the Navy.
And I told Everett Render in the folks in the front of aircraft carrier,
they call it a folksle, in Hong Kong, China.
Everett was getting out of the Navy.
I was going to be in it a bit longer than he.
Why don't you come to San Francisco because I'm going to be working for Pacific Bell?
I can get your job there.
I said, no, I'm going back to Atlanta.
Finish more house.
He said, why are you going back down there?
I said, Everett, there's going to come in time.
I believe when we're going to throw off the shackle of segregation down there.
And I want to be there.
I told him that in 1957.
I got to make sense.
So when I came back to Morehouse in 1957, I played football and it's hope wasn't so on.
And therefore I got to know a lot of people.
When you went into the Navy, did you have any expectations going in about what kind of environment
would be in terms of racism or opportunity?
Well, I think my mother had more than I.
I remember now, my mother had to sign for me to go in because I was not 18.
And so when we went down to the recruiting officer, my mother said to the recruiting officer,
I don't want my son to become a see going bus boy, was what she said.
I didn't know what that was.
And so she explained that she didn't want me going to see.
And all I was going to be doing is being a steward's mate serving the officers.
So they didn't make me a steward's mate.
They made me a deck force person.
Because she told the officer that she was signing those forms to me to go in with the premise
that he would not be a see going bus boy.
So she knew what I was going into.
And she thought she was protecting me.
I guess she did get me from being a see going bus boy, but how about a janitor?
She did put that in.
But anyway, when I came back, I played football.
I played the first string fullback for Morehouse and ran a few touchdowns for them.
And that meant then that I knew a lot of people at Morehouse and Spelman, which served me well later.
So when the Greensboro Force sat down February 1st, I was reading the news paper at Jason Milton.
Went to my good friend Joseph Pierce and said, Joe, why don't we organize and do something here?
And he read, he said, OK, let's do it.
And I said, let's go talk to the sky over here.
I said, I met him in 1957.
He was a time magazine intern when he was in high school, so he should be able to write.
We need to have somebody who can write well with us to tell the story as we organize.
And that guy was Julian Bond.
And so we went to see him and Julian was reluctant at first, but he finally agreed to sign on.
And so the three of us then began to organize.
Did you explain the military?
He basically just said that he thought all that happened.
Somebody else would probably do it, but he didn't want to get involved in the facility at that point.
But I just kind of press it in just a little bit and it didn't take too much.
I mean, intellectually he understood it.
But I think I might have caught him off guard at the time I had talked to him.
But when you read this family, his dad is history, you could realize that his dad was a tremendous scholar
and wrote a lot of great things about civil rights.
So I think that it was in his blood, but I think I kind of surprised him in the beginning of that.
But we held our first meeting of the students at Morehouse, Holandex, about 20-some people came.
And, um...
How do you mean in particular?
Like how do you mean in the early morning, when you were in school, when you were in college?
Well, I actually started with the people that I knew best. They were football players.
You know, who were blocking for me on Saturday.
A lot of them had come.
And I got people from Clark College to come.
James Feld, who was the head of the SGA over there.
But most of them were from Morehouse, because that was my base.
I learned at that time how extensive the president's apparatus was.
Because I guess within a matter of a day or two I got this call from Mrs...
Well, I actually not a call. She came down to Yates and Milton.
Mrs. Hill was Dr. Maesage's secretary.
I don't know her first name, but her name was Hill.
She came into the place where I was and she did this.
She said, Mr. King, Mrs. Hill, Dr. Maesage wants to see you.
I had three o'clock in the conference room at Harkness Hall.
And she also told you, and Joe Piers.
And we said, I said, we're in trouble now.
They knew exactly who it was.
I don't know if there was something in the room.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. They had good spies.
Anyway, when we got in the room, all of a sudden,
all of the SGA people from the other place, other schools were there,
along with Julia and Joe Piers and me.
And so, Rufus E. Clement, who was a chairman, Dr. Rufus came into the president of AU,
was chairman of the meeting and of the council of college presidents.
Rufus E. Clement said, well, he laid out that they knew what was going on.
And they talked about the evils of segregation and what have you.
But the thesis that they used was that you need it.
You got the NAACP handle this.
They're equipped to do it. They have the lawyers to do it.
Your parents did not send you here to start a revolution.
They sent you to get an education.
You can do the revolution later on.
Dr. Benjamin E. Mays, who was a second senior person, spoke next.
He reiterated Rufus E. Clement's position.
And also, he was a life membership chairman of the NAACP.
And he spoke into Roy Wilkins before the meeting.
And they're going to provide any legal assistance that we need.
Dr. (Albert E.) Manley from Spelman echoed the same position.
Dr. James P. Brawley, the president of Claw,
made what I consider to be the most ass-and-eye incumbent of anybody that was made that day.
He said that if we went downtown to sit in that we would embarrass him,
I couldn't believe that and said that, but that's what he said.
And then we came to Harry V. Richardson,
who was the president of the Interdenominational Theological Center.
Dr. Richardson waited about a good 10 seconds before he said anything.
No classic Baptist preacher, I guess.
And he began an unparaphraising.
I think the students are right.
We all looked around because he had broken the commonality that I think was agreed upon by the president before the meeting.
And he went on to knock it out the pop.
And he, in effect, said that it was time for a change.
It's going to be risky.
But he said, I have a PhD.
I'm the president of a major institution of higher education.
I can go downtown and spend my money by clothes.
I can buy anything I want to buy down there.
But if I want to stop in the nice restaurant to have a lunch, I can't go in there.
He said, that's not the wrong with that picture.
He said, I support the students.
I could see the president get upset.
But before they could settle down, Dr. Frank Cunningham,
the president of Morris Brown College, spoke up and said,
I agree with Dr. Richardson.
I knew then that we had him split up.
And he made a very eloquent speech.
He was a philosopher.
Then Dr. Clemen, I guess while he was thinking, he said, well, who's going to speak for the students?
So everybody looked at me because I was the agitator.
So I started speaking.
And I laid out the premises that this thing is growing.
The AU Center has always been a citadel of learning from African Americans.
And there's no reason why we should be left behind, so forth and so on.
When I finished, Dr. Clemenit said,
we still think you ought to let the NAACP have this thing legally.
However, why don't you write a manifesto and tell the public why you were doing this?
He said, I think you said, you from the AU Center,
we need to have an intellectual document.
That you draft, not us, but you draft, that would set forth,
quiet you were doing, whatever it is you might do later on.
Well, I always knew that that was from his perspective.
He was playing chess with us.
In other words, if you're going to still do this, let me make a chess move here,
and have you write something.
If you get all caught up in writing, events might overtake you,
and you just be the philosophers of the movement as opposed to activists in the movement.
That was a part of what I think he said.
He also said, the full page ad in all the papers, I will raise the money,
and I'll pay for it. I get it all done.
I accepted the challenge, and I pointed Roslyn Pope to edit it.
I asked Julian to join her, Charles A. Black to join her.
I think it was Marist Dillard not believe I asked to join,
but the bottom line is that all these people I knew had been English majors in some way or another,
and would write a great document.
Roslyn is so brilliant until it's just unreal how brilliant she is,
but you never know it unless you just sit down and talk to her one day.
She just stopped the kind that goes around and brag.
But that document was written, well, actually what happened is Roslyn called me
tonight before we go back and show her to the president for their approval.
She called me and she said, lining, the committee at your point had not done a thing.
She said, Julian got me some data from a second look.
She said, but the others haven't done anything.
I said, Roslyn, it's show time.
We've got to have a document for the president in the morning to write the damn thing.
So she said, okay, so she wrote it.
And then she typed it at Dr. Zin's house, Howard Zinn.
I think Julian may have typed it, but they used Zin's typewriter to get it done.
So when we read it to the president's saw it the next day,
they were very pleased at the document.
The matter made one or two comments, by and large,
about 9.5% of what Roslyn had written everybody agreed with.
It was published, Clinton had raised $12,000 to pay for the stuff.
And it cost about $4,000 and he had $8,000 left there for our benefit if we needed it.
And it was publishing that Lana Journal, that Lana Constitution,
and I believe that Lana daily were on.
Dr. Clinton, I think told me that Mr. Scott, who had the line of work,
black newspaper, wanted cash up front before he would run it.
But the white papers sent him a bill.
He was upset about that.
But anyway, that publication though ended up being reprinted in the New York Times full page free.
The Nation Magazine ran it on, we did it on the 9th of March,
the Nation Magazine ran it, full page added in there, magazine on the 2nd of April 1960.
The Harvard Crimson, Harvard Crimson ran it.
The Senate's Jacob Jabb had read into the Congressional record.
And it's for that, for posterity right now.
And it's been used all around the world by a lot of different people.
And guess the imitation is, I happen to be looking, doing some research work at recent,
on this area, in the area.
And lo and behold, I found a document that had been written by Miles College students in 1962.
And it basically was nothing but the appeal of a human rights retitle this we believe.
And Atlanta had been taken out and Birmingham had been put in.
I told Ross, and I said, Ross, the imitation is the best form of flattery.
But anyway, we started this movement, and I explained a lot there in those documents.
Now, should I give you the narrative about what happened, or you're going to use the narrative,
or what? Sure, sure.
May 17th, the boycott.
Now, I'm trying to figure out, do you want me to ask you those questions,
or should I just keep talking? Because I can talk on and on about it.
I know, we know there's so much, and so many of us are like to have you, you know, keep going,
so narrative, and come back, but it's on.
So when the president brought you all in, you and your peers, and really, and you're,
the same by the president.
And vice president, out of secretary, I think.
Three from each school.
Three from each school. Right.
Did they decide to get the student government?
The president, the president did that, we didn't.
Yeah, okay. And because I know I was talking to a few people, and they said that, you know,
some of the presidents will really never involve others in signing the documents,
and that one of them chose not to sign it, but to come there.
Or you mean the president of the student government associations? Yes, that's true.
The guy named Hickman, who was making Georgia, had a methodist,
I think the white methodist in making had given him a scholarship to come in Morris Brown.
And so he was afraid of losing his scholarship. And so Marion signed it, and as a secretary.
When, you know, out of that viewpoint of the community,
you should try to write this, and then write this for a bunch of millions.
Most of it, yeah.
And then I know at a certain point there's a committee on a peer.
That started right after that.
And so how did you, you know, I'm very interested in who emerged that the leader,
and how that happened. You know, these people were in official leadership position,
those athletes, the student government, and those people that they're converted,
so they're kind of like, well, let me see if I can answer that this way.
Once we published the appeal,
at about the time the publisher appeared, the best way I can answer this.
That was a Rump group headed by Dr. Lonnie Cross, who was a PhD at Mathematics at AU.
He took his scholarship,
and he was down there to sit in that richest before we could get there.
Yeah.
I'm just documentation.
Oh, no, I'm just, I'm just, yeah.
So what happened is that the president of the university,
the president of the university,
the newspaper of the university,
and the president of the university.
Yeah.
Oh, no, I'm just, I'm just really interested.
So what happened is that it was,
the campus was buzzing with all the activity,
so they knew what was going on.
So he wanted to get there
and put his name down before we got there.
My position was that all the schools should come together
which we later on did after it was published.
But prior to that, he had pulled this little city in down there,
with his history, maybe five or six other.
And so I contacted Rufus E. Clement
and raised with him the spectator.
We couldn't afford to have clock going down one day,
a.U. another day, Mays von another day.
I said, that is a divide and conqueror.
If ever I've seen one.
I said, it's because all you're going to do is have the virtues say,
well, who do I negotiate with?
Morris Brown or Morehouse?
I said, we need to have a one voice.
I said, what's the common denominator here?
The common denominator is that we're all African-Americans,
or Negroes.
We're all being subjected to the same kind of discrimination
by the same institutions downtown.
So to go down there now with these divided voices makes no sense.
Clement agreed with me.
He called an all campus meeting down at
at Wehrhal, E.A. Wehrhal, which is on the campus.
And had all A.U. students come to hear him and me.
So Rufus E. Clement gave the exposition as the wider meeting
was being held.
And he argued that we ought to be together.
That's the position that we've taken.
And the presence of Wehrhal and we ought to do it as one body.
And he was saying to Dr. Cross, it is kind of productive
for you to take your class down and do this.
So we got to, you know, I got to say to all of you, don't do that.
Let's do it in some kind of organized fashion.
And so he said, line up, we just plain to them what you're
going to try to do.
And so I gave the exposition.
Dr. Cross, when I finished jumped up and challenged me,
and he challenged the right to, as a professor,
to take his class downtown.
And he wasn't going to listen to any of this, dude, you know, okay?
So Rufus E. Clement said to him,
Dr. Cross, would you sit down?
So cross that down.
And then I spoke, then Cross jumped up again.
So Clement said, Dr. Cross, would you sit down?
And Cross tried to get a little bit subordinate with him.
Clement said, Dr. Cross, sit down.
I knew then that Cross had been fired, okay?
You don't do that to those guys doing that period of time.
So Cross contract was not renewed in May.
So I knew he was dead as a result.
But Clement backed us, backed me and us, all of us,
about the idea of putting a coalition together.
And so after the appeal was published, we sat down in that same conference room
and decided that every school would have three representatives
on this policy council.
And then the 18 members would pick a chairperson.
And then that chairperson, then that school
from which the chairperson comes can send another person.
So I was chosen to be the original chairman, found in chairman,
I guess you would call it.
And so therefore another person from Morehouse could be added to it.
So ended up being Don Clark, he's the president of SGA.
Julian Bond, and Abadd Branson, who I think he was vice president SGA.
But that's only for Morehouse, of course.
That's really interesting.
So at that point, President Clement, although he was trying to slow you down
a little bit, I think he was trying to slow you down a little bit.
So he was just a strategic decision that this is going to happen.
And if it's going to happen, this is the best way.
I think so.
Yes.
I think he realized that the events had overcome their authority.
They were concerned about losing their tax incentives status.
And that's why I thought it was a legitimate, it was until recently when I started doing research.
The governor of Georgia, Ernest Van der La, when the appeal was published,
said that that document could not have been written by college students anywhere in America.
It had to be written by somebody from Moscow.
And what I learned is that he instructed Eugene Cook, who was a Attorney General,
to check on the 501C3 status of all the HBCUs.
So I'm going to pick up the documents on that.
But the bottom line is that they were under siege, which we did door by at the time.
They were risking their 501C3 status, at least the state part of it, okay?
But you know, there must have been a serious conflict in the minds of the college presidents.
When you think about what Dr. Richardson said,
with all this training, climate from Wisconsin,
maize from Bates and New York Chicago,
all these people, all of this education,
and that was a ceiling.
You know, you could just go so far.
And the duality of the part of the folk who ran the system,
that duality didn't bother them at all.
That's just the way I suppose to be in this culture.
Dr. Cross, I see this whole thing as a kin to,
that period, as a kin to a volcano,
in the sense that it was simmering below the surface to all these things,
the different, I guess you would say,
different systems up under the surface were going on,
the dangerous powerful.
But you couldn't see it because the cultural sites that
you hid the oppression, it was there,
but you hid how you felt about it.
And I think that when the young men sat down in Greensboro,
that was the catalyst.
That was the one thing that caused the volcano to erupt.
And I don't see any other way you can answer it,
and 120 days, 70,000 black kids were raising sand all over the south,
because segregation was ubiquitous, it existed everywhere.
And so I think that along with the Second World War,
where a lot of veterans came back,
and when you think about it,
it says, my dad, the veterans of the Second World War
had children that were going to school at that time.
And where could you get a better set of chalk troops,
people who were in school, they were waiting at home time,
most of them, and therefore the normal oppressive means
for keeping niggers in that place,
you could not implore it because if the kid is from Miami,
how are you going to get folks in Miami to fire his mama,
or the other place?
But they tried it now because if you go back and look at what happened
during that time, every time we got arrested,
they put our name, rank, and serial number in the paper.
Even in my case, they put down, I lived at 211, 75,
and go on the road, or apartment number, 2A,
just to make sure you knew where he was.
I don't know if you'll never hear.
My mother was scared to death, but was supportive.
Let me tell you two things about my mother that I think
are important for this.
When between March the 15th and May 17th of 1960,
I was having some difficulty getting people organized
in terms of numbers beyond the 30, 40, or 50,
and I knew I needed more than that in order to make this work.
I was talking to my mother, but I said,
mama, I need more people.
She said, you've been all the way, I said,
I've been to the campus, but I need more people.
She said, well, people are afraid.
She said, go over to Spelman.
She said, the ladies will probably know who you are
because of your football staff.
She can't you organize and get the Spelman women behind you
because if you get the Spelman women behind you,
the more hot men are going to come because of the girls.
The Cloud folks will come, March Brown.
And so as fate would have it, you see Dr. Krossbissum,
when you go back and reflect on this then you said,
you know, that's a divine hand in all of this
because let me tell you what else happened.
I got a telephone call from Dr. Albert E. Manley.
Dr. Roer Wilkins was coming to town to speak its Spelman.
Around the first of April.
And he wanted me to come and present this student's view.
The issue was should we go back to class basically.
And so, and so, and so, Manley and Wilkins,
they were taking the affirmative position.
And they wanted me to come and argue the negative position.
And so, I was scared to death.
Yes, it's imposing to go and debate a man
with international reputation like Roer Wilkins.
Swal, well educated, been at this, been at this stuff for 30 some years.
So here we are, three of us up there on the stage
and the place is packed with all ladies from Spelman.
So, Dr. Albert E. Manley introduced Dr. Roer Wilkins.
And Roer Wilkins knocked it out the paw.
I mean, he was smoothed it silk.
Oh God!
But I remember I had a course in public speaking at Spelman
is to interesting enough.
And the guy, Dr. Dr. Cothrin said,
if you think you've been outgun in a debate,
learn how to dam it with faint praise.
He said, give them that do.
And then you do your however.
And so, I used my public training that I got from him.
And when I got up, I praised Mr. Wilkins like you wouldn't believe.
But it was all true now.
All the stuff that they had done, I mean I laid it out.
And so, I was like, I was making his speech all over again.
But then I pivoted.
And I made the speech about the time had come.
And I would order and I used a little ration technique on that.
And I ended up saying, Mr. Wilkins,
if not now, when, and if not us, who?
And I sat down.
And the girls went, wow.
Mr. Wilkins did this.
He said, really?
He and I, I guess you were saying the same page.
We had some other deal, I'm dealing with later on.
But those latest came and the rest is history.
I mean, on May 17th when we had that big march here,
we had almost 4,000 people going downtown.
We weeped at Spelman's campus and Morehouse' campus.
I was asking about that.
I was wondering if you know what I was doing with research.
And I was just preliminary.
But one thing I'm very interested in is women's role in all of it.
Okay.
And so of course, Atlanta is a wonderful place to look at that.
Because it seems like great participation.
But it's unherald.
It has not been written.
Okay, go on.
Well, we talk about that time.
So I don't know enough to know whether this is actually accurate.
But impressionistically, it looks like there's a maybe disproportionate number of Spelman participants relative to some of the other campuses.
Absolutely.
Is that true?
I have identified 169 Spelman ladies who actually went to jail or were out there risking things.
Now that was a whole lot more than that involved in the picket thing and stuff.
But those who actually went to jail, I think it was 169.
No more host than anyone close to that.
My Morehouse would be number two.
The clock would be number three.
Marsh Brown number four.
But Spelman, my mom was right.
The Spelman ladies will make it happen.
If they get behind you, they'll make it happen.
Do you have an explanation for why they were so responsive?
I mean, obviously you can't be getting this great talk.
But you could do that at Morehouse, right?
Or one of the other campuses?
I couldn't care as many men as I could care where men at that time.
I'm just going to be honest with you.
Women don't have something else.
And Morehouse, I think I ran into a lot of jealousy from other young men,
who position was.
You know, the line that was not elected president of the SGA.
So why don't we follow in him?
You know, but no way else was risking their life but me.
But nevertheless, I think that was a part of it.
I think it was Mayo, Jalusis, some of it.
We're talking about Morehouse Spelman participation.
The women in that Spelman, I think,
they were the backbone of the movement in my opinion.
Women don't get hung up on who's the leader.
They, if there's a job to be done, and they want to do that job,
they will get involved.
They don't get caught up on who's doing it.
Also, women don't mind following the man.
I mean, that's the kind of the way it is.
The husband is ahead of the housing.
They don't get upset about that, okay?
And I think that's one of the things that really was very helpful on that.
But we're now in May of 1960.
So I was invited to come and speak to the state NAACP.
And so when I spoke to them, I announced that we were going to march on May 17th
to the Capitol to commemorate the Brown decision that had been made six years earlier on May 17th, 1954.
I did not know that that was a report of that from the LA Constitution, Jalus.
The following morning, it was headlines.
The student leader announces massive march on the Capitol.
The town went wild.
Mind you now, they were still buzzing from the appeal of human rights,
and all of us going to jail and all that kind of stuff.
So they knew something was happening.
Well, a government event of a called out the State Patrol.
They surrounded the Capitol, almost armed with Billy Clubs and dogs,
to keep us from coming down to the Capitol.
So I had asked the students to meet me in front of the library that morning at 10 o'clock
and they did thousands of them.
So before we marched off, Ms. Hill, the same lady, I see her coming.
I knew May's wasn't a senior.
And so I told John Mack, who was my coach,
and to keep them busy while I go see what Dr. May's wants.
And so I went up there and so on.
When I got there, it was May's and his wife, Miss Sadie May's.
So May said that he had just spoken to Herbert Jenkins,
and that the ball of the State Troopers were down there with the Billy Clubs,
and what had even their whites who were gathered around.
And it looked like it's going to be a big mob mess down there.
And Jenkins emphasized that his jurisdiction ends at the Capitol.
He's not in charge of those State Troopers. The governor is.
So he couldn't protect us.
I don't think this is a matter of because you can't have a thought issue in the warning.
Asked me to not ask him, don't come because you might get hurt today.
So is he confirmed about the written person?
I think that Jenkins was a part of, he was the legal,
he was the police arm of the power structure in Atlanta.
Atlanta has a reputation of being the city to visit a hate.
It would not have been good for business if some students got beaten up in Atlanta.
So they lose some money. That's all it was about.
It's not about love for the students. It's about love for money.
So Dr. May's asked me not to go.
They got to give these people credit. They never ordered me to do anything.
They would let me know how they felt.
And so, and they gave me a chance to respond.
And so when he gave me all the reasons why we shouldn't do it
because of the risk of danger.
I said, with Dr. May's, let me take you back to a speech you made when I was sophomore.
I said, your speech was entitled, never sacrifice a principle for peace.
Do you remember that? He said, yes.
I said, you ask a million to sacrifice this principle of indesegregation
because I might get killed.
Therefore, in order to have peace, I got to leave alone.
He said, Mr. King, where are you going to end up?
I said, we should be doctors church.
He said, say that I will be there. That was the end of it.
So I went back to speak to these students and I did not know that May's followed me
until I read his book recently, born to rebel.
I happened to be reading the book.
And I went to that, and I got to that section.
He had followed me back.
And he heard me tell the students, which he described in his book,
that there were people downtown, one of the hurtest.
And this is a nonviolent movement.
If you cannot take the blows, don't go.
If you cannot afford to be spat on, don't go.
And I went through an alliteration of things that we only want people who are willing to be nonviolent as a tactic.
I'm not asking you to be nonviolent in your life, just as a tactic.
And when I finished my speech, not one of those 3000 plus kids said that they wanted to back out.
And May's describes that in his book that I didn't even know he had followed me down there until I read his book.
But he said in his book, he knew then that I had matured with the way he put it.
So what is he suggesting?
Well, I think before then, May's probably thought I was precipitous.
I had considered all the factors involved, the harm that might come to the students.
I think it was only at that point that he realized that I was very serious about this.
And I had a lot of folks behind me.
Now, I tell you, Dr. Emilye Crosby, if I did not have thousands of students backing me, I couldn't have done it.
See, because I don't care how good your cause is if you don't have any followers, you just listen to this, you just listen to Dixie.
But anyway, we went down there on May 17th that day and we marched down and there were a lot of pictures around about that.
So Herbert Jenkins, our floor mentioned, got out of his patrol car and started walking with me at the corner of Mitchell Street.
And so the two of us just walking along and he said, this is going to be Daniel's at the Capitol.
I said, yes, I know Dr. May's told me you are tall.
He said, well, I think you are not to do this.
I said, well, Chief, keep talking to me.
I said, but I think we have to do it.
So we walked up until we got to Spring Street and Mitchell, which is where the new post office, the new Russell Building is now.
So I said, Chief, if you give me a direct order as a Chief Law enforcement officer in the city at Peace Street Street, no, no, no, I'm sorry, Whitehall Street, which is now Peace Street Street.
I will turn. I said, I'm not trying to get anybody hurt.
I said, we are, we are making a point.
He said, okay, I'll do that.
But let me tell you what was my thinking.
Look at the environment. The Chamber of Commerce was a guestist. The White Community was a guestist.
Carlos Presidents was scared. A lot of parents were scared.
I said that if one student gets killed, then I'm planning to the arms of the enemies of what we're trying to do.
I said, it is very clear now that they've never had this number of students to march on anything in this town.
So I felt that I had made my point. Now I know it's a little bit conservative, but I decided to err on the side of conservatism in order to save the movement.
Because I felt that if one person got beaten up by a Billy Club, there would be forces that would be arguing to shut me down.
And so I followed his orders after I gave him the suggestion.
It was, it was hell. But then as fate would have it, we had so many people marching until about the last 200, they got lost.
And so they went on by the Capitol.
And when they got there, I learned from the leader of that part, Charles A. Black, that they, they, it was awful.
They didn't beat anybody, but they, but they were heckled by all the white bystanders and the state troopers.
It was a very menacing thing. But I saw something else about the crossbearing. When I looked at all this stuff lately, when you look at one of the photographs taken from the Capitol of that church across the street,
and all the folks that were out there, there were a number of African-American, young African-American men who were not students.
And I looked at that, I said, wait a minute. What's up here?
I can't prove this because folks are dead now. But that may have been a black vigilante group in Atlanta that could have very easily stepped into the fray if there was any kind of confrontation of a racial nature.
I was shocked to see them. And I come back to that later on because I had another chance to see something similar to that, okay?
Yeah. That may very well have been, if you want to put a pin right there, and I will just flash to tell you why I'm connected, I'm connected to them all.
So I started a boycott of this food stores changed right after that. And one of the stores that we went to was one place called Man Brothers, over in West End, Atlanta.
All the grocery stores hire Blacks as janitors and maids and stock clerks, but never as cashiers or managers or assistant managers.
Even though the business was 100% black, everybody was white who was in charge. So we pulled this boycott off over there.
And it was a high-wide act. So the newspaper in the West End had this front page editorial that sat at it before I came over there.
Because I announced that I was coming, all of us were coming. And read that they compared me to Hitler and that I was coming over there to change things.
When I got over there that Saturday, it was Charles A. Black, Frank Holloway and me.
And we were about 300 whites across the street, heckling us.
There was a white guy, about 57, who was there by us with his hand in his pocket. And we put Mays up and down with our picket sign and we would have you.
All of a sudden this white guy lunged at me and doused an acid like substance on me that burned like he wouldn't believe.
I mean, just burned my skin, my clothes, my shirt was destroyed. And I couldn't see terrible odor. Even the impacted two guys, even the impacted Frank Holloway and Charles, who were behind me.
So they rushed me to the hospital and I won't get in the honor of that except that. Well, I want you to set the stations and they wouldn't, the first service station would not let me get in the water but to leave. And then I, the second one did, allow me to do that.
Well, I learned later on that day that it was on the news.
And the pool hall was not modern, but it was honestly been a black pool hall, emptied of all the men when it came over.
They ran the West end to see what was going on. And I think Atlanta was very close to having a racial conflagration during that period of time.
But I think that cooler heads prevailed and they were willing to allow these students try to work this out.
But I think that there was possibly that potential for Birmingham kind of violence here, but it would have been quite versus blacks like you wouldn't believe.
Okay. That's just.
You think that you think that you could go through some of the names and say that and the way that you think they had a chance of, you were 13,000 in total, I part of those.
I'm not sure it was organized, but I would go with the latter point that you made. I don't know if anybody talking to them because it just don't know me.
I knew about the pool hall empty, but I didn't, but I had not seen those pictures of those fellows that were down there because it was an all white mop down there.
And I was saying in the middle, it's all white mop. What are these young black guys? Black maybe 18 to 25, hovering around back there in the background just spectators.
Let me, what's that all about?
Okay.
Where do you want me to go next?
Well, you mentioned before you went on that, you were on that scene talking to students about you know, you know, the parents were gone by.
And I'm going to take it very naturally.
They have a little sense of workshop and other places.
They do, you know, don't hit back kind of.
It's a very different approach.
Did you have any kind of training?
Or was it simply at any point in the process?
No, we did not.
Our panel, our committee, took the view that non-violent should be a tactic.
Not a way of life.
And therefore, that was a risk of us to go through all these.
Now, I don't know what happened after I left, but I doubt we were in a series of anyone actually ran into workshop.
Nashville was known for having done that.
And I can't really speak to whether that's more effective than just people adopting a tactic to be understood here.
And I know that many people have not been, but I know that there are also,
like not, and I don't even know a lot, and I know that the mix of some of those have workshop.
Just on, you know, so people have some factors to not have a bonding.
But it wasn't necessarily a thought factor.
It was still a very practical thing.
You know, it was a very few way to make it right.
Yeah.
But I think a lot of people also know that it was a good way to get that.
Let me try to rush through a lot of what I've written.
I've really covered some of this.
Let me try to rush through the Atlanta.
Let me talk about some institutions.
The Atlanta Daily World.
The oldest, it was the oldest contingencies running daily after the American newspaper in the country.
Possibly in the world, really.
They were an ultra-prod opposed to the movement, and what we were trying to do.
So, Julian was basically our arm, and I had hired Julian to that summer to write the publication
called the Student Movement in You.
We used the summer of 1960.
See, okay.
May 17 was a big rally.
Then it's exam time.
Then people are gone.
So, we had to organize for the fall, the fall campaign.
We had to also organize a boycott because we determined that we needed to boycott downtown
at Leningrad and automate them come to an agreement to integrate.
And we chose Richard's department store as the kingpin, all downtown but Richard's for sure.
In order to do that then, we had to battle with the old line black leadership who felt that Richard's was a great store, even though they were segregation,
safe segregated.
But how did you get around that?
Nine percent of African Americans in this town at that time were making a small amount of money.
That 10 percent were teachers and doctors and would have you.
But the bulk of the GNP was with the low income, $5 a day in coffee at people.
So, we needed to then organize around our strength and the strength was in the numbers.
And I remember when I was, I took economics with Dr. E.V. Williams.
I used to say that he'd much rather have the fast dime than the slow dollar.
Or he said that, hold up more dimes than their dollars.
And there are a lot of folks who have dimes.
And I used that along with another economics major named Dr. Hugo Schala, who taught me by John Foster Dulles' policy about the Domino Theory.
The communists felt that in the Pacific Basin, in fall, career falls, the rest of the basin will fall.
And it all will be communists all the way over.
Like Domino's, they fall in line.
And so I took the position that Richard's department store was like a major domino.
If we could knock down that domino piece, the rest will fall.
Because it was the largest store in the southeast.
So we took them all.
I went down there in June of 1960 for a meeting with, I sat down and I'm sorry, I sat in.
I took books down.
I took Dr. Zinn from Spelman, his daughter and his wife, myself.
I think Carolyn Long, down there to the Magnolia Room.
So they, of course, they closed the Magnolia Room when we got there.
And then Herbert Jenkins, this guy, took me down to jail.
Not to be arrested, but to have a conference meeting with Richard Rich in his office, Herbert Jenkins' office.
So when I got there, Richard Rich read as a beat.
And he talked about how good he had been for Negro citizens.
And he mentioned how he had supported the AU Center.
And he was the first one to ever put Mr. and Mrs. On the names of his customers when they set bills out.
The first one to give him charge plates, so forth and so on.
And you need to go take your, your student back to class.
And I gave him similar speech, you know, no, no, we have to, you have to change.
So Richard Rich said to me, I'm paraphrasing, if you bring your black ass down there again, I'm going to lock you up until the keys away, basically.
And I said, Mr. Rich, I will be back in the fall when I come back and bring thousands with me.
He turned redder and he told Herbert Jenkins, I'm through and he got up and walked out.
And so they took me back to my office down in Auburn Avenue, they'd teach people dead.
We're now riding this dude movement in you, Mr. Skywones Atlanta Daily World is constantly editorializing against the movement.
So we put out 20,000 leaflets per Sunday.
Through the churches we'll have you. Building the movement.
And one day in June 1960, in Wauksis, man that I thought was white in my office.
And I was a little edgy tall six foot three, six foot wide guy who had gotten all the way back to my office.
I didn't know if he was going to kill me or what, you know.
So I guess I'm up to look at apprehensive.
He sat down and he had the Atlanta Daily World in his hands and he said, my name is M. Kasuth Hill.
He said, oh, you're learning King, I suggest.
He said, I own Hill office supplies.
When he said that, I knew he had a good black guy, but he looked as white as anybody.
So I kind of, he said, this is a shame what this man is doing.
He said, now he's doing this because he wants to fight advertising.
And he's selling out the cause of human dignity.
He said, I own the rights to use the name get Atlanta in choir.
He said, I've always wanted to start a newspaper.
He said, I've got an attitude. His name is William Strong.
But I don't have any writers.
He said, if you're getting help me get people to hell with circulation,
he said, I will start it because I have an offset press.
So the two of us came together and we agreed that I will stop the student movement in you.
Have Julian go in right along with John Gibson and James Gibson and his brother and others.
Form the underbelly for that paper.
And on the Fed of Press of July, and you can find that in 1960, you may want to see that first issue.
Oh, you have.
Okay, all right.
And it's still around.
But that was started by M. Kasuth Hill, myself and the students.
It was not the folks that you read about.
They came in later.
But it was Mr. Hill who has not been given his due.
But I'm going to give him his due.
Because the man did it.
We know what else we're doing.
M. Kasuth Hill, not Jesse Hill Jr.
M. Kasuth Hill.
Did you read any sense of that in the last month when I'm happy with the world?
Oh, no question about it.
How did you learn to do that?
Well, we went to a lot of things that were happening at the same time.
We went to colonial stores and AMP stores right after that march.
And asked for these cashiers would have you.
I got a telephone call from Mr. Scott.
Telling me, C.A. Scott telling me, asking what I come down to seeing.
I saw what down to seeing.
And he proceeded to tell me that he's going to lose a $9,000 ad.
Or with the colonial stores if I didn't stop picketing.
And so Mr. Scott was spitting all over me.
Have you seen those folks who talked to you and your man in this,
that's not spitting well.
He was spitting all over me.
And so I'm just here listening to him.
Be that by me.
So I said, Mr. Scott, you know, in every revolution, some people get hurt.
But you don't call out the revolution because somebody might get hurt.
I said, you know what?
This is your time to get hurt.
I'm not going to do it.
He cursed me out and I left with the bottom line.
He didn't.
He was just brave, hate me.
And I guess I'm sure that Mr. Hill started the newspaper later.
That really got him.
Okay, because we were able to get them, they real stayed,
the black real stayed people.
We got them to take the ads out of Mr. Scott's paper and put them in the air.
So he really upset me, I guess.
He was upset with me.
But I think we, he never changed.
He was always like that to his death.
But I think we ripped his behind badly.
You know.
You can do it.
Can you stand with your first name?
Capital K.
All US-S-E-T-T-W.
It is.
Kassuth.
He was the son of the first African American doctor in this time.
And his wife was ginger Hill, who was the head,
she succeeded Whitney Young as the head of the Lowne University School of Social Work.
And I know that you look from college.
Well, it was a combination of me and Julia.
Oh, it is.
I wrote, I wrote, I had several, but I think Julia may have written about a third of them.
Because he was the deal.
Dr. Krosby, when you're trying to run a movement as big as this thing was,
you didn't have time.
You didn't have time?
I was a little busy.
Plus I worked on that at the post office, you know, on 6th, 6th, 3rd.
So I didn't have time to write to her.
I said, Julia, since I hired you, write my article,
I'm not able to write it.
And so he did that.
Oh, yeah, oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
But that was, see, once we hired Mr. M. Carl Holman to come in and be the editor,
who took over who was real strong, we then tried to merge the message
between what's on the editorial page and the cartoon.
So if you didn't read the editorial, look at the cartoon and you still get the message.
And I've got to give you a man by the name of Maurice Pinington,
whom you may not have heard about.
An event that was one that I had forgotten that I had written.
When we went to jail, and we'll talk about that later on in October of 1960,
Martin King and I were in the same sale.
Because we were the leaders of the movement, you know, per se.
And I wrote an article, a letter from the Fulton County jail.
And I forgot that I had written the article until Dr.
the doctor up, who's a school, he has the School of Social Work at New York City, Georgia.
He wrote a biography of Don Hollowill.
And he had all these newspapers.
He said, let me send you a copy of what you said when you were in prison.
Yes, I did write that, but also Julian wrote some also.
Now, there's some who said Julian goes wrote all of them, that's not true.
Julian wrote some of them in that wrote some.
You said you were in the same company, but what about Maurice Pinington?
Yes, Maurice Pinington was, in my view, but for his race,
he would have been a claim as one of the greatest illustrators, all cartoonists in the country.
At the time that Herbert L. Block was so big, Pinington was just as good.
And I wish you could see some of his work.
We're going to have a big exhibit in Atlanta, 18th and 19th of October, at AU Library.
It'll be there for 30 days.
And it's going to be there for five years, for 30 days.
And we're going to show the, as many of the artifacts as we can pass with the pool together.
It's going to be a big show, and if you get a chance, it'll be good to come back down for that,
because it's going to be a big deal.
There's just a whole lot of stuff.
There's a whole lot of stuff that people have not seen.
We have 30, some cartoons from Mr. Pinington that just out of sight, that are going to be there.
Okay, plus he took 100 and some pictures of the movement that also will be down on the action movement.
Action stuff.
There's a wonderful picture from the movie.
Where did you see that?
That's not something we know that you are a college?
Okay, yes, yes, okay.
Well, that's...
Some of them were born on one of the anniversary committees.
Oh, yeah.
Yes, yes.
Well, we've just added to that exhibit.
There's a lot more down there now.
By October, you're going to have...
We'll have enough in there to go all the way around.
Because that stuff out there is just a matter of putting it all in one place.
What I saw wasn't actually on this play.
It was in boxes.
Yeah, well, we're going to take stuff out of the boxes, and we're going to add more stuff to those boxes.
Mrs. Pinington is waiting to sign a document that I've been prepared for her,
where she's going to launch.
She's going to lend us a lot of her stuff for five years.
I try to get it forever, but five years is fine.
That would have started.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So, I know there's a lot to talk about in the industry.
But can we take a deep one and talk about the findings, then?
Sure.
And, you know, I know the basic story, but I understand that you were present at the meeting in the hall.
Can you tell me what you remember?
Well, let me just say this to you.
And this has been written that many times, and you're going to get people who are going to be upset about it.
But you ought to ask that Reverend Dr. Otis Moss Jr,
whenever you talk to him, ask him about the founding of SNCC, because he was there.
Once we got going in that spring,
I recommended to our committee that I go to meet with Martin King
and see if I can get him to pull together a meeting of all of our student leaders to form some kind of a soft wide organization.
And Moss can attest to that.
He was in that meeting.
I called up Dr. King, and I already knew him, and so said that to the meeting,
and we went down there to see him.
And the meeting was Ella Baker, Dr. King and me, and to a couple of the students whose members are gotten kind of foggy,
but I'm not even getting all of that.
But I made the argument that the people that we were battling were highly organized.
And I pointed out that we were battling the system that,
from Maryland to Texas, they're on the same page.
And I cited the fact that when Virginia passed in, I trust passed laws.
Maryland quickly passed in Virginia.
I'm North Carolina, South Carolina, Georgia, all around, all around, all these days passed the same kind of law.
Almost word for word, like Attic today.
I said, so the people that we're fighting, they're organized.
And my point was that there is no known force that I've never heard of in the world,
where you had a revolution that was unorganized.
The people that you're battling organized, so you gotta get organized, it beat them.
I said, the only example to that Dr. King might be the French Revolution,
where he said the mass as well as that.
But when you look beyond the French Revolution, look into the intercourse,
look at the instance that was the middle class there,
that was pushing them.
So Alabaca on the other hand, and this is contrary to what you read,
opposed organizing this way.
So it was a battle between her and me.
She said that we needed to allow the movement organization to kind of
She fell off from the grass roots and she used an Indian expression to,
what's it called, such a hot gruffa?
Yeah, she used that expression as the basis for her position.
Martin King said, he agreed with me and he gave, he said,
I'm going to put a 500 dollars and I want you to Ellen get a place
for us to call this conference over Easter weekend.
Of course, she finished show and so she got show to host it.
We were there.
For whatever the reason, Ellen and Martin party company doing that period of time.
So by the time she got to the conference, she either was out the door,
or was about to go out the door.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
My impression is that Miss Baker,
well, I'll put this one.
A lot of African American preachers are very showvinistic.
And Miss Baker, from their perspective, did not know her place.
And she was an outspoken person who would say what was on her mind.
And that always got in trouble with these preachers.
And I think that might have gotten in trouble with Martin King,
to be honest with you.
And if not him, some of his people around.
So we were there, Dr. Abbott Davis, who was the head of Atlanta Medical Society,
rented a brand new 1960 white Buick for us to go up there.
So six of us in the car who went from Atlanta to that conference.
And I think Johnny Parham, who was also part of our group,
flew in from some other place, but he was there too.
My recollection is that it was Julian, Ben Brown,
I think Marion Smith, Marian Wright Edelman.
And I believe it must have been Child of Frank Lyle, the other way LES I think.
He's a guy from some of you who went to Texas.
But anyway, we all were there.
And so Nick was formed, as you will know.
A lot of, it was good to sit 300 people roughly there, under the same umbrella.
Now there are those who claim that Dr. King wanted Nick to become a junior arm
of SCLC.
I don't want to doubt that he didn't, as far as that, but he never talked to me about that.
And I don't know anybody else that he talked to about that.
But there were those who felt that that's what he was trying to do.
They may have evidence.
I don't have the evidence.
Of course, I honestly believe Dr. Emilye Crosby, considering the man's charisma,
if King had wanted us to become a junior arm of SCLC, it would have happened.
I mean, there was nobody there who had the force of ouratory that could have overwritten King.
If he had wanted to do it, but I didn't see that happen at all.
I have a very small technical question, some details questions.
I know Marion Barry were in the first chair of the Temporary Coordinating Committee.
But I've seen different things.
Some people say that he was elected in April.
And some people say he was elected for some documents.
I mean, it's a variety of different kinds of doubts.
At the first May coordinating committee here in Atlanta.
Do you have a recollection of that?
Yeah.
Marion Barry.
Okay, that was a battle going on here.
My name got put up as the first chairman.
The folks of Nashville brought in a guy, Marion Barry.
That never heard of before as their candidate.
I thought it would have been Diane Nash, but it was Barry.
So you had this jock in going along.
So finally, a compromise was reached.
Less you'd like Barry as a temporary chairman and remove the headquarters to Atlanta.
And we paid the rent for the first several months.
And the records already showed that.
I mean, I've got the records on that, okay?
That office paid the rent.
I hadn't seen that, but I have seen some of the financial records that showed that the Atlanta group
was putting on the donate.
Right, right, but it was for the rent.
But my position was we need this organization to coordinate and would have you.
There are some people who have the view that if you didn't write it down then it didn't happen.
That's not really true, but haven't said that.
The move to Atlanta was the best thing that I think stick could have done.
I don't think they could have done it from Nashville, okay?
In retrospect, from an outside perspective, it seems like the logical move.
It was logical because Atlanta historically has been the citadel of intellectual thinking
and action in the Civil Rights Movement beginning really with WB Duboy.
And when he was there, you for 20-something years, and he had all those wonderful things that he did over there.
It's unfortunate that this town until recently has never recognized this man's genius.
It's been clock AU just put up a statute form, but that's been one of the things.
They name all these streets after people who have done nothing in this town or in this country.
But because they're part of a certain click that can get these things done, how about a guy like Duboy, who was a giant,
not just in the United States of America, but in the world.
It's an interesting town, I put it like that.
She should have been there.
Diane Nash, in my view, was the Nashville Movement.
And by that I mean this.
Others were there, but they weren't Diane Nash. Diane was articulate.
She's beautiful woman, very photogenic, very committed.
And very intelligent, and had a following.
I never did understand how, except maybe it was sexism.
I never understood how James Bevel, Marion Barry, and for that matter, John Lewis kind of leapfrogged over.
I never understood that because she was in fact the leader in Nashville.
It was Diane.
And the others were followers of hers.
Now James Lawson was going, well he was in the James Lawson, but he was an adult who was kind of working with the student.
But it was Diane.
So I never understood that to be honest with you, but she's a real unsung hero of the movement in Nashville, in my opinion.
Risk of life in order to make this thing happen.
I think some accounts, and I'm like, you know, again, you know, you know, a few of those snippets here and there, and you can see them, and I know there's a different kind of, some of it, there's some certain that they believe in some of these contradictory.
But you know, one, one account, and I think Marion, very serious, is that the expectation was that Diane Nash, that the Nashville Group wanted to put Nashville in the chair.
And they mentioned the competition with Atlanta, but that at some point, or some meeting she wasn't present, and he was, so he became kind of the person.
The consensus? Well that may have happened because they were having the meetings, you know, because we didn't know anything about that part of it.
I was just shocked though when they came back, when Barry's name was put forward, I was shocked about that.
Because she was the one who literally put them on the map up there.
Now was that at Shaw in April, or was that in the land in May?
Diane, well, we actually elected a temporary chairman in at Shaw, pending going to the next meeting.
But Barry, by being the temporary chairman, also being the chairman anyway, you know, if you ever get that first leg, yeah.
But I never understood what the Nashville folks were doing when they overlooked the lady who really brought them to the table.
So did you have a sense of her reputation? Oh yes.
Oh yes. Oh yes. Diane Nash was, in my view, Diane Nash was the most articulate advocate of the movement at that time.
And I never understood what was happening in Nashville, beyond it, just you. Except maybe sexism.
Did you have a sense of other leaders from other communities before that law in the United States?
Yeah, I had read about David Forbes, I guess his name, I had heard about him.
And I had heard about a guy named...
Forbes was that Shaw University.
Not even David Forbes. David Forbes, not Franklin, David Forbes. David Forbes.
I had heard about him, and I heard about Ed King, who came to Snick, who was put out of Kentucky State.
And I heard about a guy named Robinson, who led the movement down at Southern.
I forgot Robinson, why wasn't it, why didn't it go to the Marvel Robinson? Marvin Robinson, yes.
I heard about him. I heard about the two sisters down in Tallahassee.
Is it...
Yeah, the dad is a pastor. I had heard about them.
I had heard about Chuck McDo in Orange, Burst, South Carolina.
Who else?
The movement down in Savannah was being run by the NAACP. I had heard about Mr. Laws, but you told my students now.
I heard about the students being kicked out of Alabama State, but I didn't know any names until August when Bernard S. Lee came to join us in Atlanta.
Of course, you knew the names of the four kids from Greensboro, but I never met them.
In fact, you know what? I don't recall them, but not those boys with them. Were they there in the Ad Raleigh?
He's a player for school. He went to a school with a coordinating committee.
Oh, okay, okay.
Yeah, come to think of it.
Now, there was another young man, but I learned about him late on after Snick. I got started. That was Hank Thomas.
And another guy who went around Hank all the time, Reginald Robinson.
But I heard about them late on during the year.
How old did you get back to the other man?
When you came to the Ad Raleigh, you were born in the 18th century.
Not too many people who were known and well were able to describe him and grow old.
I was born in the 18th century.
Yeah, I have a picture of Ed King. Ed King.
Is that one of the demonstrations?
Yeah, Ed King is the first person to come in here to help us as a secretary.
The Ministry of Office was Jane Stembridge.
And the second person was Ed King.
A lot of folks who want to try to pretend like they don't know Ed King, but Ed King was here.
And he actually was running this office full-stick.
I don't know why people want to write him out, but by the way, he died in January of last year.
I've been trying to find him.
No, Ed King died in Montgomery and Prince George's County.
Yes, I can get you the newspaper stuff. I'll send it to you.
Ed King, I've been looking for the man.
And so finally one day here, I said, let me go find him at King because he never comes back to these reunion and would have you.
And I looked it up and sure enough he died in January of 2012 in Prince George's County.
And it is the same person. He was born in Virginia, which you probably know.
I'm not sure whether it's Ron Ork or what have you.
I know how he was expelled from Kentucky State. That's him.
I felt badly because I had one of the breachums several years ago, but didn't know how to find him.
I come to find out the man was less than 30 miles away from me.
But he just kind of dropped out of sight.
Yeah, I know you know back to school. You know, you know, high.
Or were before?
So can you describe him for me or his role?
Yeah, Ed King was. Ed King was very effective in being a coordinator at at SNCC.
He worked very closely with us in Atlanta movement.
And a person that was especially close to him was Marion Wilson.
They were very close.
Ed was an articulate speaker. He was courageous, well organized.
He did a job for SNCC at the time when we needed somebody.
And he's kind of unharrowed, be honest with you.
And there's another guy named Ed King who's a white guy, Mississippi.
And a lot of folks have refused those two, but there were two Ed Kings.
So I know there was a person.
A town.
I only knew there was a mile one and we got, you know, and we had all the way.
Well, let's go as far as we can.
Yeah, yeah.
Once you ask all you want to get all your questions in,
then I do my best to weave other stuff in as you ask questions.
Because I want to make sure that I answer all your stuff, okay?
Well, you know, some other people might be thinking about some of the big points.
So why don't you tell me, I know we talked to some of the boy called active women in summer 1960.
You know, you resume those big campaigns that Atlanta students and the fallers.
And I know you have those.
You know, the big events that might mean the change in some of the strategic decisions that will happen in spring.
I know that you want to talk about some of those things that you think are particularly significant,
that they are, I think, so that's the most important.
Well, we put the plan together.
Once we got the inquiry going on, we began to get people joining us.
We spoke all over town, trying to build up a grounds for the fall campaign.
And it was too prom.
Sittings are confident with boycotts, so forth and so on.
And by the way, I just found out here recently, Richard's lost $10 million during that period of time, that I just found out.
Somebody from the mountains who are involved, say, you all were looking at stock exchange?
Yes, we were. Yes, yes. Yes. Yes. Yes. Yes. Yes. Dr. Hugo Scala.
Yeah. And Dr. E.V. Williams. Yeah.
We watched them every, every Sunday. They stopped publishing after a while.
But anyway, where was I?
I was talking about the two-phone, the purchase.
Yes. Yes. So in September, the students were back.
We had the plans.
So I presented the summer work as part of the fall campaign.
He's what we want to do.
And I had to battle, believe it or not, with the AD King, Martin's younger brother, and Bernard S. Lee.
To try to get that approved, the issue was, do we wait till October the 19th?
Or do we go now?
And my point was, we want to time this with the Presidents of the election.
So they were even in the study. They wanted to go. They wanted to go.
They wanted to go now. Now, now, now. And so we said, no, miss.
And so I prevailed only because the Spelman folks backed me.
You know, they backed me. And we waited until October the 19th.
Now, my answer, I had Carl Martin King in August to tell him about
what we were going to do. And he agreed to come at that time.
And so her share of Sullivan, Herschelle Sullivan, came back from Paris in September.
And she became the cold chairman to take the place of the guy from AU, who they graduated, John Mac.
So she was, she led the Spelman delegation.
And I convinced her to back me on waiting until October the 19th.
So on the 18th, I said, her shell, give him a call.
Give Dr. King, I call him male, but give Dr. King a call and tell him to meet me on a bridge
at 10 in the morning. So she came back and she said, no, he said he can't go.
Oh, the riches, yeah, rich, at Riches Department store, on the second floor,
that was a cafeteria that separated, that was over the street between broad and for
safe. And it was like, yeah, you could sit in the cafeteria and you could look at the traffic
going up and down those streets. It separated the store from homes, which was on the left
side from the regular Riches facility. And so when she called him, he told her that he
couldn't go. And I said, but her shell talked to students here. Let me go talk to her.
Because I knew I had a relationship from 1945, you follow me? So I called him up and of course
on the phone was his daddy. Believe it or not, AD was on the phone for some reason,
instead of being out there, he was on the phone. Wyatt T. Walker was in the room.
Yeah, they're all there. And so he, in his very slow, different way, he said, I can't
go because I was arrested and I'm on probation from an arrest for bleeding Smith out in the
county. And if I get arrested, I've been advised that they probably revoke my parole,
not parole, but probation, probation. And so, and his dad, of course, he was bombastic,
you know, daddy came. Anyway, I ignored daddy came and other folks on the phone had just
talked to him. And I said, email, Atlanta's your hometown. You need to go with us. He had
never been the jail of a lot of Ontario before then. They would come and get him. I said,
but if you get arrested with us, it'll be international news. And I think that that's what the
movement needs. And I said, Martin Luther King Sr, do you remember a sermon that you preached
a few years ago called, you can't leave from the back. Got to leave from the front. I said,
well, email, you can't leave from the back. You got to leave from the front. That was designed
to silence his daddy, who was on my case by putting it back in his face. And they also
had a mail here that sermon too, because he was there. He said, they'll see, they call me LC.
He said, where should I come tomorrow? I said 10 o'clock on the bridge. He said, I'll be there. That's how that happened.
Well, I believe a talk to Harris Wofford, who's still alive, by the way. I was surprised that he was
still alive. I called him and left a message for him when I found he was still alive. And I got
a call back on my answer machine where he wanted to know if this is a lightning king who got me fired.
Oh, God. And so I called him back and I said, yes, yes, I did get you fired. And of course,
he told me later on about what happened between him and the kin of this and all that kind of stuff.
Of course, he spoke out of school when he did certain things. Anyway, having said that, when
the kin was arrested, it was like a firestorm that went all over the community, all of
the American, the black community. Now, African Americans have been voting except for Roosevelt for
Republicans since 1865, 1867, I guess. But when Kennedy interceded or his brother and interceded
and Kennedy got the credit for it, after he called Coretta Scott King, it switched the votes in a lot of different states.
You know, Illinois, Michigan, all over the place. There's been a difference in that. It was not the dead
people in Chicago. It was a lot of African Americans who voted with their feet for this guy named Kennedy.
Because they didn't know Kennedy from anybody else. A lot of them didn't like him because he was Catholic.
But King had become by then a symbol of change in the African American community. And that's why they switched over to Kennedy.
The historians have tried to minimize the arrest of King by giving it, most of the world just used earlier,
them in with faint praise. But the reality of it is that, but for that arrest, Nixon would have been president.
And all of the stuff could have been different. You know, had Nixon become president, okay?
I don't know. I wasn't that involved in that part of it. All I was trying to do was to put the issue of civil rights.
On the front pages of the People's Agenda for this country. And I figured that the person that could do it was King.
And I also felt that the students in Atlanta were organized until we could make it happen.
And of course, that is what happened. Interesting enough, though, I've learned as I've done more research lately.
Richard Nixon did prepare a statement to get involved with the situations and try to neutralize what Kennedy might have done.
Because he was going to call Alberta Williams King and he prepared a statement and gave it to E. Frederic Morrow, the black assistant to the president, during that time, to present Howard.
He said, let the old man read this statement because this is what I'm going to say. And when I was now a guy at the statement, he said no.
And so Nixon did do it because he didn't want to buck the boss. That was a fatal mistake on his part. Because what would have happened if Nixon and Kennedy both had spoken out against the injustice that was being perpetrated on King?
It might have neutralized the election and Nixon would probably have won.
I lost it.
How well organized it was?
Oh, yeah. Well, I think there were two things that were involved here. One is that I went to the middle chair and learned a lot about how to organize.
Plus, I grew up with people who were in the civil rights movement. They were down at the YMCA at the time and I listened as a boy.
Sucking all this stuff up. Plus, there was a guy who returned here and we called him El Comin Dante. He was a retired master's sergeant, I guess he was.
And he came by and asked me if he could work with us. And I told him, yes, he said, I'll work full time. No pay. I think it was a tie-dread.
And so Comin Dante came in and got with me and he was able to pull together a lot of blood. He put some meat on the bones that I had come up with.
He was not the one who put the ingredients together. He was the one who put the plan together. Like the end, you mentioned the two-way radio.
Let me tell you how that came about. Walkie Talkies. Every time we were done, the merchants had a survival strategy.
They assumed that if we came in and we probably came in by bus or we came in by car, once you close the lunch counter, we would go on about our business.
And so that was that tactic. When the students show up, don't arrest them, just close.
So our response to that was, it was a chess game. So our response was to get us some walkie talkies, two-way radios.
And we have teams of people who were downtown with radios in their car. At our communications headquarters on chessness street, we had, like a central, our lives, place that was where we could talk to all of them.
And so we had spotters. So let's assume for instance, Richard's department still closed the lunch counter, the the Magnolia Room.
So our people were going and leaving because they weren't going to arrest them. They knew they wanted to be arrested, so they weren't going to do that.
So when we leave, they'd open right back up, but what they didn't know was that we left centuries around and the walkie talkies.
And so what they would do is that they would call and say they just reopened again and send us was there. And we sent people right back in. They never figured out what we were doing.
And so we really harassed them so finally they just closed them all. But a guy named Ronald Yancey, Ronald Yancey and another guy who died on the Pueblo in Black and Stromes County, they developed that communication system for us.
And they actually ran it from over there. Ronald Yancey, he was by the way the first black person to finish Georgia Tech.
He lives up in Columbia, Maryland now. He's retired.
Many instances telling you, and I saw a little news that the clip about it, that absolute one year's of reunification has to be at the decision of handing down that the land of things have been so reunified.
Well, here let me go into that. On about the 4th of December 1960, the court ruled in Boynton v. Virginia that you shouldn't have discrimination in the interstate commerce on these buses and trains.
So we had a committee meeting in the next day or two and we were discussing that issue. And so we decided that we would go and test Boynton v. Virginia.
We sent a team to Chattanooga, Columbia, South Carolina, Jacksonville, Florida, Birmingham, Alabama.
Yeah. Marion and her sister, I think, went to Birmingham, I believe.
And got arrested, I think when he got back to Atlanta. Yeah.
Mr. Maurice Pennington, the same artist, and his nephew and Mays Dillard went to Chattanooga and got arrested.
Norma June Wilson, and I've forgotten who went with her now, went to Jacksonville and they got arrested, now they're making Charles A. Black and Otis Moss Jr, who you might talk to later on.
They went to South Carolina. They were histled up in Athens, but they were not arrested.
The idea was to test this decision. Claude Sitton, you remember him?
Claude Sitton wrote in the New York Times a few days later about the city.
I know it was written, I don't have it, I can probably get it though, okay?
But he did write it. And James Farmer called me and asked me, he told me more about it.
And I told him, he said, well, you know, I tried this earlier. He said several years ago, I didn't even get too far with him.
We did it kind of up on the other side of the nation, the nation of Dixon and Lyon. He said, I think maybe we want to do it.
I said, okay, I said, well, when you're going to do it, he said, I'm going to do it in the spring.
So he said, remember you're going to come through Atlanta. I said, when you get to Atlanta and get your call,
and I'll come and talk to you on. And sure enough, when you got here, we went over to Clark College where they were standing, we did talk to him.
I was looked at the NAACP files recently in that the Library of Congress.
And there's a letter in there for Marvin Rich, remember him? Marvin Rich to Roy Wilkins, detailing how they were planning the Freedom Rides in the spring.
That letter was in February of 1961.
The answer question, yes, we had the first one. It was the first one, I guess it was in modern times.
James Farmer had done it earlier back in the 40s. That's right.
But I think it was outside the South, though. Right.
But we have pictures of all of that.
We have pictures that will be a part of the exhibit. Pictures of Norma June, Wilson, and Marion, and Norma June, Marion.
And I believe we may have him appinant in two. And I think they have a receipt.
All that's going to be there.
Yeah, yeah, it's going to be there. But these are the things that have not been brought out, but we're going to have more with that though.
I mean, I know one of the things that has been written about a lot,
that's the relationship between the students and the adults.
I called my 19-year-old grandson who came in.
Okay, we're back.
You know, what happened in the spring of 1961, and I don't know,
but it compromised. I don't know if that's something you want to talk about.
I'll be happy to talk to you about it. On the 1st of February, 1960,
well, no. Back during the fall campaign, the Chamber of Commerce types,
in the mayor, all of them got all involved in China's settlers, but the white merchants were not agreed.
The powers that be in the white community wanted to try to see if they could find a way to settle the situation on their terms,
on terms both labeled with them.
And so there are a series of meetings out in the black community,
on with these Negro leaders, who were not in charge of the movement that were going to be negotiating for us.
Well, once they put all these plans together,
as well as they were going to integrate everything, after the schools deserigated in the fall.
No, after the schools deserigated, not in the fall, but whenever they did it.
The someone said in that meeting, I wasn't there, but I was told by State Sen. Leroy Johnson.
Someone said, well, who's going to say, we don't control the students.
They won't even meet with us when they're going to do strategy.
So, how are they going to tell a line of king? We can't do it unless we get him involved.
Did you know they were having meetings? No, no, no, they were doing it behind my back.
So, Jesse Hill Jr said, well, I can get him to come to a meeting.
And they said, can you get him to a meeting? He said, well, he trusts me.
I can get him to come. And sure enough, Jesse Hill Jr called me to ask me to come to this meeting,
the chain of commerce.
Most important meeting of your life. I said, what is it about, Jesse?
Trust me, trust me. And so, I said, okay.
So, when I got to the meeting, here were all these powers that I've been battling,
along with the black leaders that were pushed to the side because they didn't have the troops.
I had the troops, you follow me?
And so, they presented to me the proposition.
They were going to integrate by this time, now, that's a court decision that the schools have to integrate by fall.
See, they first had those meetings in the late December, January, but then the court ruled.
And so, they were going to do it now after the schools opened, deserigated.
And so, they wanted a verbal agreement with me to do that.
So, nothing I can do that.
So, Martin Luther King Sr jumped up and he said, I'm tired of you, boy.
You're going to wreck this time. I baptized you.
And so, I just ignored it. And the iron never old, Dr. Emilye Crosby,
is that the man who came to my defense in that meeting was a man named Frank H. Neely,
who was the chairman of the board of Richard's department store,
who was sitting directly across from me and had been hitting me on my leg with his cane.
He said that, he said, Rubbin King, he's the only one who has a constituents.
He was elected. We all appointed ourselves.
Because, I said, let me take this proposition back to the group that I'm representing.
And that's what upset King, okay?
I was snookered into a chamber of commerce meeting.
For some reason, I was thinking that it was a meeting that was with the Black leaders.
No, no, the Black leaders were meeting with representatives separately.
But then they pulled us meeting together because they had to get King,
and you had to get me into it.
Herschelle Sullivan joined me. I asked her to come with me, right?
She didn't even say, but she was there. I wanted witness.
Well, when Neely made that comment that I was not wrong,
Ivan Allen Jr Jr and A.T. Walden call for recess.
And this time, Rufus E. Clement came over to me,
and he's the president of the AU. He came over and said,
you were trying to rock in a hard place. I said, yeah.
He said, you damned if you do, you damned if you don't.
And that's all he said.
KB Williamson said, I don't know what to tell you. That was a real statement.
And then it overcomes one of my great, and I was a great admirer of mine,
and I was a great admirer of him.
Mr. John C. Calhoun, who had been the head of the NAACP,
with gone to jail rather than give up the NAACP list of the governor,
who's one of the father's teachers. He says, learning,
I think you ought to go along with this. I said, why?
You saw you were aware of that. This is the first time
that we've ever been able to get white folks in the South to agree
to voluntary do a whole set of disarrigation without it being mandated
by the federal courts. I said, yeah, I'm aware of that.
He said, I'm 60 years old, and I have been
still getting every day of my life.
And if I have to wait for March to September,
when I can go downtown and do, anywhere I want to eat,
spend my money without being put into the back or put into color section,
he said, that's a short time. He said, I know you don't like it.
But I recommend that's one of your advice that you go along with it.
I thought about it, and I said, when we reconvene, I said,
I will go along with this on two conditions, one that is in writing,
and two that I also be able to go and present it to my students.
And that was kind of the way the thing ended.
When we left the meeting, and before I could get back to the school,
Ivan Allen Jr Jr had held a press conference.
I guess he had to press out there in the anti-group somewhere.
He announced that the NIGRA student leaders have agreed to end the boycott,
and that the lunch count was open to be open tomorrow segregated.
And that was all he had to say.
Man, that was a firestorm in this town.
I mean, a literal firestorm.
That was when I think the whole town realized that the community had backed us,
and they were upset because they knew that we were probably close to victory.
So I went back and presented it to the students, and her shell and I resigned,
because we've been really just pressured into this mess.
Did you, when you followed the deadline,
you coming back to the team, and you were going to get the news going?
No, I did not.
I just went back, and I resigned, her shell resigned.
And the students unanimously refused to accept our resignation.
So you've taken us this far?
Let's call a mass meeting and see what the public thinks.
So we call a mass meeting for the 10th of March at Warren Memorial Methodist Church,
not at rest at all.
Dr. Stinson's Church, Warren Memorial Methodist Church,
and over 2,000 people showed up inside.
I don't know how many folks outside had speakers all over the place.
It was a while, while session.
They condemned all of the adult leaders for what they had done.
All of them.
And you know, Martin Luther King Sr got up and said that he'd been fighting for civil rights.
He was trying to get an order for over 30 years in this time.
And before he could make the other sentence,
a moment in a white dress, nurse got up and said,
and that's what's wrong.
And when she said that, the place erupted.
King had to sit down.
Well, I had spoken to ML earlier.
He had just come back to town. He had a little cold.
I called him up. I said, ML,
I need you to come and calm this crowd down.
I said, I'm nervous about what's going to happen here.
I said, they just booed your daddy.
He said, OK, I'll be there.
He was on sunset.
No, he was not there.
So when he got there,
I told the Rev. William Holmes Borders Sr that he was there,
because Rev. William Holmes Borders Sr was in charge.
I said, would you let ML speak?
So when King got up there,
man, he made the greatest speech of his career.
The March on Washington speech did not compare to what
that man did that night.
He took that crowd to the mountain top, to the valley.
He mixed a lot of different speeches into one speech.
He had tears in his eyes as he was talking to him.
He said, I get booed his daddy, OK?
But the one thing that he said that I think
he really carried the crowd with when he said that
the agreement may not be all of what it should be.
But we cannot afford to have the cancerous disease
of this unity in this community.
What's it we do? We'll lose.
We got to back this.
It's not perfect, but it's a start.
And if people calm down, he literally calm that whole crowd down.
I mean, the guy was a pied piper.
So my now the students and the town kept the boycott going.
I mean, even though the agreement was there,
they still wouldn't go back down to the shop.
Reverend Wilburn got up.
James Wilburn from Union Baptist Church got up there.
And he said that we're not going back down town
until after September.
In other words, if you go into the Great Incept Temple,
we'll come back in September.
But it was a very, very powerful meeting of conflict and force.
You had the students, you had the young adults, the young Turks.
You had the old guy.
And he had one or two whites in the audience.
I have an alum was in the audience.
The former man, he was in the audience.
He was in the audience.
And in one of his things, he wrote that he did not realize how powerful that man was until he went to that meeting.
Spied.
He sat in the back.
Way back in the back.
So it sounds like from what you said that I really said that vast majority of the people in the community,
the leaders, the President and the King,
he was really against that situation.
Absolutely.
But that is a small group of traditional leaders that made this, that negotiated and wanted to put in that,
you know, once you are already in that position,
then people went along with it because of that mission of the community.
I think so.
Yeah.
And here's a deal.
I think that a lot of the people were angry because we had been, I had been tricked.
A lot of them were angry about that.
But on the other hand,
I think that the more sober people realized that we'd never been to this place before in this town.
And I think that they just decided to back down and let's just see, we're just all going to go down town.
But let me tell you, the one thing that has not come out that often,
you know, I ask at the height of the boycott,
I ask people to send me that credit card, that rich is credit card.
I ask you a rhetorical question.
If a college student asks you to send him or her your credit card that they would just send it.
Three hundred and fifty three people sent me their credit card.
And we put in a safety deposit box at Citizens Trust Bank and sent it back to them when the boycott was over.
I'm telling you that because that tells you, even though it's a small number,
that's telling you the breadth and the length and the depth of which this movement had reached the masses,
not the classes, but the masses.
You know, when people believe enough in what you're doing to say,
I trust my credit in your hand.
How many of those folks knew Lonnie King, a college student?
Who's he?
You know, I'm not some prominent preacher.
But we had been, but people I think saw that I was honest about trying to steal anything,
I wasn't trying to get in here, we were just trying to end the system of segregation.
That's all.
And people backed it.
Again, it's that fast-dying versus the slow dollar.
So, if we're going to wrap up the video, say, is this personal history?
I'm going to let you care, and I'm going to respond.
Well, I was actually wondering if you'd like to, if you need to answer your sentence,
or if you need to answer it, you can go ahead.
When you'd like to say a few words about how you could impact your life,
and then you can see what specific significance it should be used to in the last ten minutes,
like in 100th form, and perhaps you can follow up to do another format or another day.
Dr. Emilye Crosby, I see this as a continuation of,
and during that began in my life with my granddaddy.
When you think about him recruiting those Swift descent memberships,
I mean, he had his college turned known back as a preacher,
and I'm sure he was alive because he was a preacher,
because to be a member of the NACP,
even in some of these towns today, is dangerous.
And so I think in a way I was in the right place at the right time,
with the right whatever, to be able to bring all of the stuff to bear in one place at one time in 1960.
But I was just one of a lot of people, at least a hundred of us, I think,
in different places had a similar kind of a role,
some much larger, some a lot smaller.
The thing that I see in retrospect is that the civil rights movement of the 1960s
was the greatest movement in this country since the Indian of slavery.
Because what it did was the movement acted like a volcano erupting that became something akin to a giant firecracker
that when it got to a certain apogee, those firecrackers that explode and things just going to simmer down.
When African Americans, Negroes, channels of system and one,
and got into Title VII, where it had in it the section,
dealing with discrimination based on race, color, creed, national origin, sex.
That opened up the floodgates, or that creed of the umbrella,
that creed of the groundswell for the women's movement,
the Latinos, the Gays.
And when these things, these embers began to flow back down,
they reached all kinds of people.
The irony of it all, though, is that the masses of blacks who,
may have lost their lives and whatever, they're still at the back of the bus in terms of economics.
And women have taken over, they have become the conductor almost of the bus.
When you look at the Fortune 500 companies, they're proliferate all over the place.
Hispanics are doing a great job, even though they're trying to hold them down,
they're doing a great job of beginning to inculcate themselves into the mainstream.
Asians have done the same thing.
But I cannot just blame the system entirely on the plight of African Americans.
I think it also has to do with a lot of African Americans not preparing themselves
as they should for opportunities as they open.
And for also not being long-distance runners, too.
You have to accept, in my opinion, that there are going to be people around who aren't going to like you,
who don't like how you look, what you wear, or what you color you.
That's always the case.
I mean, people don't go out in Mariforcs that don't appeal to them.
So you got this prejudice going on that's almost in eight.
But how do you overcome it?
You overcome it by changing the laws, and hopefully you can change the customs
and the long run, change people's attitude.
But not enough of the African American community, in my view,
is willing to realize that many of us were born looking up at the bottom.
And in order to get out from under the bottom, you've got to work.
You've got to hustle, you've got to work.
A classic example is one that you may have seen in the newspaper,
and I only met some in BC the other day.
There's a young woman in town who finished high school
at, there's better deterrent of a class a few days ago,
a young black woman.
She and her sister, finished high school,
as a sluritor, had another high school.
The two of them, plus two other siblings,
and their mother, have lived in a homeless shelter
for the last several years.
You have to turn out the lights in these homeless shelters at a certain time.
So what did this young woman do?
She put a blanket over her hand, and she used the light from her cell phone to study.
So now she's coming to Spelman College on the full scholarship,
getting the first bed that she could not sleep in in years.
She's not coming as a freshman, she's coming as a junior,
because she took these advanced courses
when she was going to high school,
and she wants to become an oncologist.
I don't know what her sister wants to become,
but apparently she didn't say,
oh I'm black or I'm female,
oh I'm in these bad circumstances, the question is,
how do you get yourself together to get out of that circumstance?
And I don't think we have enough people in my community
who are trying to encourage,
who are trying to write the right kind of thing on these young people's slate.
That's a part of my problem as I see it.
So I'm going to go to my grave, maybe later rather than sooner,
but before I grow, I'm certainly hoping that I can convince some more people
to take a second look at what's happening.
We cannot afford to blame the system for everything,
because we are part of the system,
and we need to do our job to try to get these young people
that's the hope of this whole world attuned to looking for the top.
Thank you.
Okay.
This has been a presentation of the Library of Congress
and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.